last gentlemen for the third year in a
row we are taking our show down to San
Diego for comic-con sorry we'll be
airing a week of shows live from the
Spreckels Theatre in San Diego we got
lots of exciting stuff planned great
guests including Will Smith going to be
on the show Joel Edgerton
knew Mira Paz dave franco olivia munn
justin theroux zach woods Michael Pena
Kumail Nanjiani
Abbi Jacobson plus a really big surprise
for one of the nights it's so secret we
cannot say what it is you're just gonna
have to watch it's all happening
Wednesday this is next week Wednesday
July 19th through Sunday July 23rd for
more information visit team koco.com
slash comic-con
I love Comic Con it's always a good time
the hell was that yeah what was that I
don't know Andy it was like a blur and
then suddenly there it goes again
yeah yeah I felt it this time I don't
know why but suddenly I
I feel creeped out oh wait I know why
you know the superhero flash he's saying
that was the flash no that was his pervy
cousin the flasher the flasher yeah the
flasher he goes by you so fast you're
not quite sure you saw him but you kind
of get it creeped out queasy feeling
maybe we can see him if we replay this
thing in slow motion just a part of what
I just did Billy can you do that yeah
give me a second
you see that night she ran right by that
was definitely the flasher wow you could
definitely see it in that slow-mo replay
yeah that's right Annie that's the whole
premise why would you have to repeat it
did he do that the second time Billy let
me see
[Applause]
you're right Andy in that second slow-mo
replay we saw him even more yep he sure
did
just repeating stuff like you did guys
that creep
you